our next guest is a Grammy award-winning
artist who loves a good old-fashioned
puzzle also she's married to a spy kid
please welcome someone that I love but
also really respect and I can't wait to
wait a minute Meghan Trainor
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
this is
I have been counting the days my heart's
proud to meet you first of all I fall in
love with this woman
you come onto the scene you take
everybody's breath away then I find out
you're from Nantucket yes it's an
extraordinary place to be it's gorgeous
okay so
um you are married to a spy kid
a man a man
I'm not married to a child I'm married
to a spy man now
how did you meet him oh there's a couple
stories but um the first one ever I was
a I was like 18 years old as a baby
songwriter out here in LA and I was at a
songwriter Hollywood party and he
crashed it with two of his friends and I
was like Spy Kids is here and I I went
right to him and I I usually my fangirl
so hard and I don't say anything but I
went right to him I was like are you spy
kids and he was like yeah and it was
really nice and then two years later I
became a famous pop star and I was
friends with Chloe Moretz and she I was
like I want a nice guy I just I'm sick
of all these mean guys I want a nice guy
and she's like my best friend's the
nicest guy and then we went on a double
date and we've never been apart ever
since
it's interesting to me that you were
also able to have a baby congratulations
made one made one section how do you
think you were able to accomplish with a
newborn how to be making an album in the
middle of schmilkus well luckily I um I
produce and record my vocals myself so I
I do a lot of work at my house I built a
studio in my basement and then I told my
co-writers like we can start at 10 A.M
but I'm wrapped by 6 p.m because I'm
there for a bath time and bedtime and
that made it like all worth it and great
I fell in love with you because you came
onto the scene and somehow you knew to
defend who you are what you are
body positivity when they did that video
and they elongated you and you got right
on you said no and your lyrics in in the
song about I'm up all night you know and
worried about my body type yes how do
you do it I think um hearing people when
I talk about like my mental health or my
body positivity they're like same
they're like you say a lot of the things
that I feel but I'm too too scared to
say out loud and I wanted to give a
voice to that in my music because I need
it for myself and and now with this
album it's with motherhood it's with the
mom guilt of working so much it's with
posting things that are only perfect and
not posting like me sobbing because I
don't take pictures when I cry Chris
um but like just like I didn't want
people to think my I would get
interviewed all the time and they're
like you're a superwoman everything's
great you love your body you're so
confident I'm like oh no I do all this
because I don't feel those things you
know I'm working every day I'm trying to
better myself and trying to love myself
more and that's what these songs are
about out so when me too video came out
I was like I've I'm the base girl that
ain't no size two why are you breaking
my waist I'm very clear about I don't do
this who did this you know so I was like
take it down that's not what I stand for
um
[Applause]
I wanted to thank you as a woman a mom
like a girl for so long you've also
carried this strength humor
like over to social media and boy
okay you're I mean
you are crushing it on social media
which I think is just so wonderful and
fun you are like
and your bestie Chris Olson is here and
he's all over your post how did you guys
meet Nantucket years ago he's also a
nantucketer
but um on Tick Tock we like dm'd each
other recently and then he posted an
Instagram that was like I'm just up all
night thinking about Meghan Trainor and
I was like I love you and then we we did
a podcast episode with my brother and
then we did tick tocks together that day
and I was like we need to do this more
and more and more and I have an album
coming out help me and so he's been the
best best friend ever
I know the people okay now I hear that
you are single Chris I actually
aggressively singled
since about
january-ish December announced it in
January okay how would you feel if we
set you up with some eligible guys oh my
God
I think I could do that yeah okay
okay it's so nice to life
[Music]